thank you very much for being present at 7 at
this session I introduce myself my
name is laurent sion I am a customer
she generates at google only submarines
and generates for those who do not
necessarily know our domination jargon she
is a pre-sales engineer  so I
am technical part and I work
exclusively on the api management part
of google what is called the
google api management solution to
be more precise so we call that we
call to pick so api api management
at pierry management  rather than
giving you a pitch, we chose to
ask a client of our clients to whom I would
like to present his vision of these two
subjects to you and therefore I am pleased to be on
stage accompanied by Xavier Guardian
and Olivier  riccio both from amadeus
must drag the click earth and
the course of this session worked better
very simply we will start with
xavier guardian who will remind us for
those who do not yet know
what amadeus is  what does amadeus do and then
why does amadeus use api
what does this use
of api imply a payroll management solution
will be the first part then
olivier will speak for a
straw is precisely this
api management what are the expectations  of amadeus
in terms of api management why
to sum up amadeus chose is to
find in happy j what fulfilled
corresponded to its expectations
and then I will end with the time that
these gentlemen moreau have left to
give you an overview precisely
from dati j by directing on the
important aspects that we will have seen previously
with xavier olivier but in essence
generalize a little bit also so that you
will all find everything there in about
50 minutes - the too long presentation
that I am in the process of  doing it is an
ambitious format so we won't have
time to take a test if
questions in session normally but we
will be at your disposal said known then  s
out of this room or at the stand ask
googling to start an exchange if
you wish here we will be delighted good
just the floor to xavier thank you
laurent hello everyone
so we're going we're going to go quickly so
indeed I'm going to give you some
context on amadeus to understand
why we are talking about feet management
so amadeus you heard it this
morning that it is the world leader in
haiti in travel in
concrete terms commercially its 600
million reservations per year is
1.3 billion  of passengers boarded
each year on our systems,
we are going to come back to these on the concept of
reservations and on the concept of
passengers afterwards, so our job
overall is this more or
less virtuous circle which starts from inspiration,
the moment when you  want to go on
vacation you don't necessarily
know what you want to do you know very
well what you want to do there is
a whole sequence of two processes that
will come to you  nner of good ideas
to leave then a
very classic shopping phase shopping as
you know it from thong basketball
then we have a booking process that we
separate from shopping it's not just
about orders the booking is
something very  very specific to the world
of travel it is to govern we are at the
limit of the notarial act
it is the famous pnr which you have
heard a lot about in recent
months and therefore the business of booking is
very specific very formatted in our
world  such attacked
international air travel agencies so there
really we are under constraint
of industry standards
then the pre trip part between the moment
you have booked and the moment you are
going to leave
you will be solicited by a number
of content services  that
you may not have thought to
put in your booking files
or corrections that will be
proposed to you and finally your trip will take
place
we have a battery of  systems that
manage travel so things you
typically see top luggage
storage check-in boarding so there you are
involved in happy travelers and
services that you don't see you all
who have port hero everything
airlines but  the business of
the airline
to end up with post laughs of course at
the analytics of revenue management to
help our customers to start again on this
virtuous circle which I spoke to you about at the
start so our customers who are they
of course the more or less one  half a
million agents what there is on the
planet
finally half a million who use the
amadeus system the airlines
we count 700 today on our
system the airports all the
online grain companies
the hotel chains the
rental companies  car kroes ferry and
insurance all that is what we will
call content that we make
available in terms of
amadeus deployment and 15,000 people of  years 190 country
191 in fact because I miss a
point
in new zealand in auckland where
we still have an office I know that here
from an operational point of view we are
around 50 petabyte with
peaks at 55000 tps and  we process
about 3.8 billion transactions
per day which also gives you an
idea when we talk about the stones and the
management traps of the magnitude
we are talking about so this slide is for me
who made the most
important product manager  alpilles it's really
in the DNA of our company
in fact we have always been in
korea reply mode in our company with
on the one hand what we call content,
that is to say these companies which put
their content on  our disposal to
sell it so it is the companies that
inevitably go the airlines the hotels
the railway companies which make
available the rooms of the seats of the
cars that we sell and on the other
side all the actors in the sale of its
trips  so  all the agencies the
companies the tour operators all
this clientele there and to connect them
we have always been on a
paid model very governed at the start
by the edifact format which is also
defined by iata in fact which is our
communication standard
structuring messages in the world
of travel
and it has always been in edifact
for more than twenty years we communicate
between our customers and the content so we
have a strong history of messages that
pay off that has slipped little by
little we have been  creative when he says that
this email we encapsulate lady college
in xml so that it doesn't show too much we
ended up doing native
xml anyway before being overtaken by sg zone and
the evolution of technology so
today  today we have a mix of offers and that
they go on all these
technologies there and that is our
reality today of having to live with
these different technologies so the
big trends that we encounter and
then that you all encounter it's an
exponential increase in traffic
we are on 40% lags per year
including stress on our machines which is
absolutely unbearable
in any case difficult and at the same time
an evolution of technology with
standards  which is coming so today we are
playing with soap xml with the young people we
are not safe from a new standard
in one year two years three years which
will call into question all our drums
all our portfolio of epi in  place
knowing that we really have a lot of
looting and if the format changes and that
we always have to develop it
quickly poses a big
investment problem for us
our customers want to move
towards a much simpler mode of
service today they have  a strong
dependence on what we do with them we
have and we are still very much one-
to-one with our customers a strong
demand also for collaboration between
customers here too we have not always
been very good at  putting our customers
together we are always one to one
and then the security which increases
more and more with its constraints in the
world of travel specifically what
do our customers expect the
travel industry is an old industry
it is  to say that the haiti part is
necessary for them that is
what allows them to grow but
fundamentally it is an old
industry and an industry test that when
it invests in a technology hopes
that this technology  going to last a long time
it's not at all we don't have at all in
front of us people who are very
happy to redevelop their
involvement every six months
it amuses them very little for them the
stability the durability of what they  are going to
buy
it's important so solutions that
will last over time
a technology at the same time necessarily
it's the five-legged sheep to a
technology that will be easy
cheap because the travel industry
works on  fairly low margins
so the Haiti part is not
particularly pampered in terms
of investment so our
customers will have a
fairly marginal investment logic and
then always the same it has to
work everywhere device
agnostic  so for it to be cheap
efficient and sustainable and agnostic 2 to
device so a little complicated to address
at the same time the content that we have that
we absorb into our systems
and excessively fragmented as much the
airlines it  is very well
governed the messages are structured the
same way
the verbs are all the same but as soon as
we touch the railway or the hotel
or the ferry there are no more rules so
in fact each of our providers have a
different behavior and  so we
need in the alpilles to absorb a
complexity of message structures which
is not simple knowing that in the end and
there is no question of making a
framework by type of deep  ur for
our customers whose customers want to have
a single point of entry into amadeus and be
able to call the same way
of the hotel quarter era
so we have to absorb the complexity
of our content from our providers and
that  we offer our customers
the strictest interface nine is possible
this is what brings us to the
conclusion why we chose
to work with angie est first
before working pizy to think about
a system of looting management c  is
that our customers want to be less
dependent on our architecture so
we needed an intermediate layer
between our architecture and our customers
which abstracts the complexity which
allows them to have the feeling
of interacting with a unique product a
problem also of time to  market
our customers want to be able to quickly
now sign up on the system
started playing teams ya it is
tested
we come from a world that is quite
secure where we have we  has
certification in place so there we have
to ignore all that and our customers
want to go very
quickly with activation same thing activation in
productions must go much faster
and finally everything that is monitoring
analytics
becomes really very important for  our
customers and it is not particularly
our strength so all these criteria there
the key management platform of delhi
will bring it to us thank you xavier so just
a small dead pot of introduction you
have the product management point of view
of xavier I am responsible  from a
department that operates the
management support and web services platform
I am also responsible for operations
so I will give you the user point of view
of someone who must
deliver a platform that meets
the scalability criteria  that is to
say traffic evolution resilience,
that is to say to be able to be
available with a we will say a test
the committees with our customers is
not one and it's just a goal much
higher than 3 nine
so we also have a scale effect which
is really substantial we have to think about
that we have to say to ourselves that tomorrow it's
bigger, wider and much more
resilient I  am going to take 5
main drivers when we look at the
points I mentioned to define a
management reception platform and in
general it is quite true in all
amadeus first point there is an
ecosystem there is because we are 30
years old  from experience we have always evolved to
evolve this ecosystem but we must
integrate
a typical example is our system of
permissions and authorization with
our india bins
those who serve the api a in fine is
consumed and that we expose  to our
customers therefore this system must internally
integrated with standard solutions
such as high and we must rely on
this integration with a product or
support management a trap management
platform and the ghetto and who will take
the tra  fic
the second point is given
the failure to which we operate
we have to automate everything we have
manual automated processes but in the
end because of the integration that we are
carrying out we must be able to
automate the entire chain of
command  we are not going to provision
each client each reception
today we have thousands of clients
on the web services with iai management
we cannot manage it how we manage
one of the pets
we have to manage a herd that is
also the point on  resilience
we cannot achieve operations
greater than 3,900 automation we
must remove all forms of
human intervention therefore all your
reception solutions management you must
support autonomy automation to
achieve integration stability and
security is essential
the interesting point  what to review
and that we had certification processes
we knew our
customers we entered into contracts with
them  there were indignant the client
was completely authenticated
today with approaches like
open sky where we expose our spines on the
internet without having close knowledge
of the client
we have to rethink security security
and ones and it's at the beginning of the  product
not after we do security we see
how in the mouth so vpn firewall all
that disappears that's not the
security
layer the security layer is antony from the
moment when it authenticates and applications
that send traffic to us until  'to
our India bins and that we must be
able to audit is permanently we have
personal user data so it's
the most important thing for us we
must guarantee I'm not even talking about the
obligations of pissia and ss or jd
pierre at amadeus security is at the
heart of our concerns personal data
is gold i talked about open eyes pillay
we must access the data looting
he was consuming and we changed the
par  adigme of access today we are not going
to see a given company
we are going to see someone who can be a
developer who will come from the internet to
say it hey I was eating spinach
is from amadeus so I am registering an
address  e-mail what is
an e-mail address
I will give him a key he will be able to
consume the support my support on
our portal
he will want to build a prototype he
is a system
he takes his credit card he  puts the
credit card and it goes into
production and there too we out of modesty for a
day or two months because we have a
certification system
of deep customer support no
there the customer is in production as
quickly as possible
we are talking about  minutes we don't talk about me
the last point that is important is
we no longer have a single point in the world
of consumption looting on our
scale we distribute ourselves all over the
world we are multi cloud multi location
we must be at the  closer for example an
example  e type c noé pillay
we sell them with a certain
quality in terms of performance and
responsible
simply the latency to consume
our and looting from the united states
well it is a brake on the adoption
of others and looting today  the
millisecond counts and you have to
understand it
, moreover, one of the successes that made
google so the question we have
if we look at amadeus and amadeus' culture
of engineering amadeus we have a
strong engineering culture a typical example
most of the managers are ex-
developers in development
or operations jean bout
developer we made a
lot of our middleware as soon as they
weren't available or because
it wasn't economically viable
so that's it  is the initial question is
what we do but what do we
make our own solution
ourselves because we believe we can
do it
the question we can ask
is are we  in our core
bus  iness and does anyone do it
better so we did our
very formal analysis of make or by we looked at it we
even said let's be fair let's look at it from an
external point of view and
also recommend a second make or by study  to
an external company and
let's compare what did it tell us it told us it's going
to cost you a lot of money a
management reception platform it's an environment that
changes very quickly and our analysis
told us that's it by  compared to our criteria
of stability, resilience and monitoring
of the great standards high his wheel which
are key for our taste buds jim is
good on average everywhere a lot of
competitors
excel in one area maybe
we don't need it
so we  was really fair in relation
to what we chose and the
selection of api ji is based on in fact
I would say a good approach on
took part in pia and then we're going
to talk about it a little bit and the part  of the
cloud vision therefore
the technical vision of am  adeus is
important in the selection david j
what I was saying we will distribute and
deploy we go all over the world we
are multiple ward
we are agnostic we are deployed
at google at amazon and our own
datacenter for us and in a private club
with openstack
so  the question is how can
I fully deploy on
multiple occasions closer to my
client it is economically viable and where
I have a guarantee of being able to have
stability we also have a
stability guarantee by deploying in multiple
sites
our solutions amadeus and committee
three years ago also deployed its
own past we adopted massively
through our initiative
amadeus cloud services 6 docker and that
bernie you are it's our vision it's no
will pay more applications
we  we operate containers and
we already had a vision that I would
call close to micro service in the
sense that we did not have monolithic applications
we build  uit of years build
farms and with india bins and we
evolved this vision towards a deployment
on the cloud and this approach with
hubert ni test on which we are
excessively committee you should know that case
for example we communicate the
functionalities of a cube  hernia tech
we also have a very strong partnership with
red hat in this on this subject will not be
a chip that allowed us to
accompany us and choose an
agnostic solution because you varnish test
today is
practically becoming the skate  pain of the
datacenter on top of that there is vision
that we have and the technology discussion
that we had with the pj is to have an
inclusion of press on Wednesdays
service to expose and its api there are
micro services the appiah which  we
are also interested in the vision that the
ghettos and of david j the mackerels
gateway
and that is very important because
it is the hybrid ghetto mode and which I was
talking about just a little bit later is
that we  can deploy our cakes and
like containers on a grid that bernie
tess and there we see that fiji fit together
in our vision with a because berne
it s operating docker containers the
last point is really our
multi cloud vision we are everywhere the
support it is consumed everywhere we
just want deployed in each location
and a micro ghetto is today for
us it is a docker container we
recover the docker file on the internet
and we bild
the micro gateway the container of the
micro gateway  and we expose cluster in
a cluster cubières speed I don't know
if you're familiar with who berne
was strewn with pods and his friends that
containers and we deploy it in
any occasion for
us each location it's a virtual datacenter
hop  hop hop a virtual datacenter and this
virtual datacenter there are micro get
well i the hybrid gateway vision is
interesting because if we
fully deploy all the ghettos  and and
all the analytics in each datacenter
how can I have a global vision
of the consumption of may walk to the
vision that we have of the analytics is
consolidated to see all the data
of all our users in a single
point and  to be able to concentrate all
this data
so the vision is that really the
ghetto microphones and all the data go back to
a central point the central point
is also very important if we have
ten fifteen twenty deployment in the
virtual datacenter world will not manage
10 15 20 configuration
each configuration is addressed to each place, so
we will check to have a
centralized view of the blue print of our
deployments and to
automatically deploy all the configurations in a single point
in all the virtual data centers
in the world and that is
essential and safe.  is only made
possible thanks to the support ghetto and the
lootings of the control take which governs the
whole platform and that we will
pay ourselves p  as we preferred to
leave in the ca in the cloud
operated won't pay for it fast j it's not
really our core business we
know that they work well on it
so cno metrics named sorting when we
choose the metrics we want  let
go up we consolidate them there is we
benefit from the consolidation of all
the metrics and environmental also
in an infrastructure where we know that
in the future the match in learning will
help us with a certain wind failure we
hope to benefit from the technology of
google to  being able to help us process
our data having other products
is a gold
mine analytics so the reality is
that we must be able to analyze this data
found data it can be
new products for our customers it
can  be operational help
to understand what is going on
automate our
chain of operations even more it's really
critical
today we even consider our
own data  acenter in this vision, that
is to say that our own tools
we are in the process of deploying them
as api haye we have a lot
of tools for the
automatic dock automatic
ticket covers find everything that is road
cause incident  management and that's
my own job we even use
line management to do that why
because we know they use what
why when is it possible to draw
new metrics and increase our
product here
I am going to hand over to laurent  thank
you thank you olivier and so I am taking the
floor to follow up on what
xavier and olivier have just said to
give you a few elements
on the subject finally on the
solution behind this program
I would like to start from 2 2
plantation extracts  previous
xavier spoke to us about the importance
of promoting APIs and their
consumption and with olivier we will
also see the importance of the intimate relationship
with the  infrastructure and with the
services that underlie these api and
it is indeed quite our
vision also the api not an end in
itself to the presentation of the api the api is
really what connects the
users to your services by
users who are yours
collaborators customers prospects
or who are the collaborators the
customers and prospects of your partners
it is really the purpose we do
not expose an api without this purpose of
consuming a service serves a purpose
internal or external trades once
again so of course for it to
work well you have to be excellent
throughout the chain you have to
be closely linked with
batten services you have to protect
this weekend in terms of security in terms
of  traffic management
you have to have the tools for a
team to pia and then this design and
functionally api that
correspond exactly to the needs
that we want service with what we
forgive them for the user experience
that we want to develop
so that's the first part it's
the exposure then the other end of the
chain is once we have api
but we have to  that they are easily
apprehended by an actor who appears
in this chain and who is the
developer in the broad sense
the producer who is responsible for
the user experience therefore of
the application which provided these
famous users of which I speak therefore
to activate  really this
complete value chain we need a
solution that embraces the entirety
of this chain
that is exactly our our life
of a platform dedicated to taking
care of all this problem which
for us really participates in the
part  management so that's a
vision that we have defended and have been defending
for several years now,
which makes us a pioneer in the
field, which has resulted in
recognition, in particular by google, of
a real  the platform that allows you to
secure to expose api with
agility on keeping pace with age at the
same time we gave you more
degrees of freedom to be able to have
applications that advance faster than
the bins while supporting well
heard your scalability we saw that
it was an extremely important point
with amadeus but which can also
absorb part of it with the progress of
caching which is really extremely
important which brings a lot of
value to our customers the
management development part which is to
allow people to actually consume these
APIs autonomously
and then finally vacation your applications
are used monitoring of uses
monitoring of the quality of service all
allowing you to build
applications directly related to
your activity so the famous system
of  commitment over a haiti which
is not necessarily not always made for
that we have digital native customers
it's perfect by consuming native api
internally we also have a
lot of customers with a
heterogeneous haiti different systems which
may have for some of the usb
never heard of sb our digital natives
and we don't have to google  there is no sb
but of course we are quite
capable of working 2 usb completely
complementary so a solution that
covers all of these
problems which constitutes the worst
management we will start with I
would like to give you some examples
and  we will start with finally the
result once you have api you
want them to be
used and therefore for that you
need to communicate with your
partners
why not your
internal developers also to offer them this
list  of services available in the form
of a country so here we are going to come to
solutions of the porto lui developer type
which is an important axis for us of the
three major pillars of the  stack
management you have examples there
all the screenshots are from
mappy clients i this is the best
example we can
give you so save portals you
can find online with
examples here in two  domains
completely separate in at walgreen we
are
more pharmacies grocery stores a large
chain in the united states yes if today
you have to do more on trading
send sectors its
really affects all sectors and you
see what towards is a company that
has  need to integrate with the services
offered by these companies such as, for
example, to promote the
islands and the services that you would
offer and therefore we have a portal that
allows you to offer to be a focal point
of information with the  list of services
available from a functional point of
view and then all their
functional documentation technical
functional technical and for some
of these external portals since ic  i
necessarily if i can show them to you
it is that they are external portals
a marketing dimension of course
so once we have the really
catchy documentation part
functional documentation we will go into the
details we will really see the list of
api  available and for a developer
it implies having a
fairly detailed documentation which goes
directly to the documentation of the
apei in addition to technical information
on parameters from default values
possibility of testing direc
ly directly online you recog
ize  I think amadeus has recognized
its developer portal and who is here
so the developer from this
functional documentation and this
very technical
round trip documentation allow him to
immediately understand your services in a
few seconds a
few minutes a developer can
know how  our APIs work
what you propose we were talking about
decoupling a  with the backend indeed
this developer does not know anything about the hate bins
behind it but that does
not concern me it would only make me
waste time for your teams
also it is a time saver
since there is more support or
support  much less a light sport
for this adoption once the
developer became aware of
what is interesting is to be able to
access the services talked about the quick
signup the possibility immediately of
going into production suddenly of
course there will be  intermediate stages
of tests this type of media
also allows management of the
life cycle of its excesses so a customer
in a similar way without obstacle can
go so far as to
obtain access keys to your services
hours this is an overview  behind this
interface, which is generally rather
rather attractive, there is a great
functional richness depending on the
case depending on the uses the
customers will use all or
part of  e its features
so I could cite
such complementary features
so the documentation we are a cms so
it also allows non-
Haiti users published documentation
to animate this community of
developers and then monetization
also we see more and more new
skies which allow you to
monetize your country the developer door hall it is
important for the ipad apps held
fast externally in be too big to be
to see but no reason that a
developer external to your company
and all these facilities for  apprehend
take note
use your api that it is
complicated internally poi internal developers
so of course we will have the same and
it is the majority of its customers
also have an internal portal developer
many new skies are indeed
huskies two countries
a term that  it was for part the
result of my api and i want to
promote them to my consumers
good but these api it  had to expose
them explode them on the platform is there
we are rather on the part on foot
all had and I go up to a
screenshot of the solution this is also
an interface of course completely
web so on the left part  but we
are a bit on the start of a
journey we are either specifications
so there are formats today they
are popular whose governance is
totally open free formats 1 time
three times to do so it's
automatic
some pilots know swagger
so that's what allows you to define
an interface contract between your
country consumers and and
apple's suppliers so the
solution allows us to start with
this design force approach
if you want and then to  the other
end we will have our APIs deployed in
production used you have a
screenshot of a tool that allows you to
see concretely what is happening what is
happening and see on this little diagram that
I don't have for  detailed but we have
a call from a country that goes through api j
we see concretely what is
happening in a fight solution
allows you to apply different
treatments that will allow you to
secure in a few seconds a  api
without touching the tray s in effect on the edge
of adding strong cash 2
but also why not you to
pay you can see api
internally with a fairly fine granularity
and want to make a facade
something simpler to consume for a
user an external consumer
you can also choose to remove
certain fields for example a lot of
transformations you can also do
on the platform through a
graphical interface as you can see which
is very easy to use at first
but which again  also a
great functional richness and you
can do it too it's quite a lot of
frameworks from amadeus a
completely programmatic way to
integrate you into an automation  tization that it
is made necessary by
very high objectives in terms of availability
quite simply because you have a
proxy that is being developed today where
you are in the process of setting up and
which involves, for example, verscio born
of the code of  launch unit tests
to have continuous integration the
tests therefore continue to move from one
environment to another really manage
the entire life cycle of your
api makes it the api solution j and itself
completely controllable by api and
l  nice drag and
drop gui i showed you earlier
is just a client of its api's that you
can use that you can integrate
with tools that are here on this
big death on two wheels scene
of des lifecycle  api provides you with
enablers for my vein for example
for jenkins this sort of
stuff goes so it allows you
to automate to also integrate with evo
identity and workfl management monitoring system  ow of
continuous deployment etc
I have a great functional richness
the gateway their courses
globally all these entry points
there okay so obviously there is a
large security part and all our
customers in one with the aim
of opening their api  to their partner or
to their mobile users have an
absolute prerequisite which is to secure
their paid as an actor so we
will see very different methods of
distribution of the platform and as an
actor also for
many years with a
massively used platform are at nearly 2
billion calls more than 2
billion daily calls on our
platform security is essential is
understood has increased further with our
complete integration into google but of
course security is extremely
important c  is a prerequisite for
all three goals in this
area but more
importantly is all the
other functions.  onalities that allow you to
really size and
tailor-made APIs to connect them to your balkans
to automate them to manage their
life cycle
so that's the part it's the
ghetto part and it therefore allows you
to expose  concretely api so you
have users from there
you want to follow
the use of analytics sela November 7 this area
it is always with customers the turn
the poor relation when it comes to
making solutions out of them  custom for
example that's why we have porn the
thought from the beginning this analytics
the most obvious materialization are
these dashboards found the
dashboard you see here are first
by default by only exposing you
a  api on happy j whether
or not you want to transform the solution
colleagues metrics without impact on
performance at the synchronous mas
obviously oh no you can
precisely monitor the availability and
response times which consume
that  she version of a country which device
with which is what I told you that at
each alba cannes you call
what methods remain you call
all kinds of information
again completely completely by
default and if that does not  not enough well
you have the possibility to define your
own metrics so at google we
collect no data per month on
everything pelo from one of your api but if
you wish you can easily
define in a few seconds
or from the graphical interface  or
again programmatically
collecting new metrics new
new axes decomposition for example
a payment api you can
easily output the payment amount
as a metric that you are going to be
able to collect graft and then
compounds by type of payment
there too which  would be a
custom decomposition appendix like everything else
dashboard but also donkey hm
but also co integration  complete via
an api that allows you to collect
two words escapes me to question we will
say that
all your metrics or
aaron's sextant the metrics the default metric
once again to integrate them
into others in our solutions  and then
we are also working a lot
on massive data export solutions
that will facilitate the big data of a
machine learning in a completely
integrated way a pigeon so there we saw
some overviews of the
key functionalities of course there are many
others and we can do complete workshops
on the solution we will
now move on to the
underlying architecture why this would also be
a key success factor for
a management trap program I went through our
vision was to have a solution that
completely embraces all the
issues of pia and management
we were really the pioneers in this
field the part of a clean sheet
we designed a completely
integrated solution  to address all these
issues, the objective of starting over on this
clean sheet was also to
base us on an up-to-
date architecture, therefore at
the state of the art, why why
did we want to be on
cloud principles just to be able to achieve
objectives of
multi-cloud distribution robustness scalability and also
organizational with multi-tenant for
example
so the api j solution is in
fact based on different components including
the active component here of abyei service
is really listening to your
customers
' calls processes them  secures them transforms them
manages cash calls one or more
bac.n merges responses sends them back
to your customers this component there it is
distributed 100 singles poynt makes it one
you can install it on one two
three cases datacenter or on a vm in
a six-volume corner
do I not have plus all of the other
components comes in addition their
unavailability does not affect the availability in any way
é complete of the
platform
you can also make them redundant
if you wish so we have
management components which are the
famous components or not to pilot the
platform to automate it to
integrate into this the
iis service developers therefore the
portals  developers that you
would like to have internal external and
then of course the analytics so
the whole thing is multi tenant which
also allows you to have a centralization
of governance will define calm while
leaving different entities more or
less freedom to expose their
appetite that too is an
extremely important point I was
talking earlier about api haiti but
this api haiti even this api team which
does not worry about organizational or
virtual form must not be a critical path for
your country either  a new silo and this type
of functionality also allows in addition
to good
governance practices to achieve this
objective
extremely important point this
solution is available in
different ways and so I come to
this on this second slide historically
we have always had to pick cremis
and saas men we only develop one
solution
we deploy every fortnight or so
on our saas platform without
service interruption with availability
we were talking about 3.9 earlier we
reached 5 9 availability last year
after in adsl at we are
committed to 3.9 4.9 depending  of your
needs so we have a client who
wishes to have everything that I am going to
show subscribed and in 24 hours at the
most we provision all of
these environments of wonder and the
client immediately has something that
looks like  what you have what you
have been able to see regularly is what
we ran in saas are the
package is available to us our
customers a premise so we have
historical premise customers for
questions of two cu  ltures for
regulatory issues this kind of
thing so these two methods
existed and then we know so much we
follow the trends and the
needs of our customers there of course
so multi cloud olivier mentioned it so
the cream in fact it becomes  from multiplayer that
you have things at home to api
that will run locally but you
also want to run the
platform yourself operate it yourself
but in your gcp instances
preferably in google cloud platform
but we are agnostic we don't  is not
intrusive on your choice of platforms there
is of course and then it is the hybrid
that we see really emerging more and
more in particular on markets on
the European markets
for the hybrid we arrive at the ski mentioned
olivier  api j we will manage the
management components of the analytics storage of the
data
the developers door hall the
management interfaces
certain api you will want to put in the
cloud
and then for the rest you  you can
choose to
have part of the ghetto on your own datacenters and on your
gcp instances another part is therefore
one - of the deployment of the api you
will make your choice some api are
must stay with me for the reasons
for good or  bad reasons
it's in question 16 to country goes
round with you for others the
test environments can be
with you got environment to grow
with you and then finally for a
third category you can
dry them all with apij so that's it for you  gives
great flexibility great freedom in
the choice of methods once again
it is the same solution from which you
also benefit from the quality of
service of all the innovations that we
bring its the platform either a
saas platform from a point of
infrastructure view for customers who
are interested in the hybrid and then
by lan cremis we have we are
also in line with the evolutions of
the infrastructure therefore in the form of
con  tainers orchestra possibly by
cuban was this both for
the installation of the
platform itself and for the integration
with managed services orchestrated by cuban
was this so we are also very
advanced and of course the fact of
being part of google  is a is an
excellent way is very close
to the hollow teams for those who are
interested in this
infrastructure part we are also very
advanced at the moment on ischios that
some may know which
allows services to be managed at a
higher level by  compared to q1 métis and therefore
all services deployed in the studios
will be completely managed by api j
without you having to manipulate or
implement automation autonomy yourself
this will be by default these are
the understandings for all our openshift customers
like amadeus the fact
of  interests that a half-breed is also a
choice is also a guarantee
of integration I stop talking to you about
different functionalities is
different architectures but I
would not like to leave you without
telling you about the different means of obtaining
more information so we ourselves
but of course are completely
available
to discuss with you via your
google contacts or directly you
can contact us also via pyj
dot com and then on this same site you
will find a lot of resources
the freelancer policy is really
open you can test the product
i showed you you can get it in
seconds log on to a
pyj signs and in and you get it in
a few seconds  minutes what we use
what our customers use and
you can make your own your
own idea
you also have a forum so alas
afflicted communities community do a
pij point net you will see for a forum
publishers somehow extremely
active managed when login  I bet
by logging in the last
question will be less than an hour ago
okay
so this shows that there is really a
real activity a real energy
around our solution don't you will find there
articles questions articles
on governance technical questions
answers here is good
news bad news in
any case  it's transparent the academy
also all our free e-learning and
online to familiarize you
with the api the design
remains as well as the use of the solution
the administration of the solution a
lot of resources also
for developers  so with
ebooks resources also for
rather management on country strategy
here is therefore a great a great
opening I still have to remind you so
really the api or allow you to
connect your users or
users with your services by
lending to be able to play a  important role
and really help you with this
platform which therefore allows excise
once again all this  you chain between
these new users and your
services
here I thank you we thank you
I hope this session interested
you thank you very much